One simple solution is to take our list of nodes—
let's say we have four of them—
and connect the first one with the second one, the second one with the third one,
the third one with the fourth one, and the last one with the first one.
Then we have, trivially, and Eulerian Tour through this graph.
Here is my code to do what I just described.
I wanted to create a graph that was a little bit more fun
but still had an Eulerian Tour.
Here's another version that introduces a little bit of randomness.
Let's say we start off with 8 nodes.
In the first step, I pick two random nodes and connect them
and choose a random node among the nodes that are connected—say this one—
and connect them and repeat this process until all the nodes are connected.
Then classify all the nodes as being odd or even.
All the nodes in orange have odd degree, and the other two are even.
We then pick a node in the set of nodes with odd degree—say this one—
and connect it with another node that has odd degree.
We'll connect it to that one. These both now have even degree.
We repeat this process—pick this node, connect it with that node.
Now we have two nodes left that have odd degree.
Unfortunately, they're already connected.
What we can do is pick one of the nodes with odd degree
and then randomly pick another node with even degree
that it's not already connected to and connect them. So, maybe this one down here.
Now this new node has odd degree. The one node no longer does.
Now we have two nodes with odd degree that we can connect.
Just to verify that there's an Eulerian tour,
we can go through here over to here connecting up with this guy and there.
Here's my code that does what I just described.
In the first step, we pick two random nodes and add them to the graph.
While we still have unconnected nodes we continue connecting everything.
While we still have odd nodes, we continue connecting the odd nodes.
One question that I'd like you to think about and answer on the forums
is whether this loop is guaranteed to end.
If so, why?
There's a link below in the instructor's comment where I'd like you to post your answer
and read what some other people have to say as well.